Speaker 1: All right.
As many of you know, one of the races that
I find to really point to just the absurdity
of the United States of America is the Georgia
Senate race in which incumbent Democratic
Senator Raphael Warnock is being challenged
by a man who has already won the Republican
primary race.
His name is Herschel Walker.
He used to be a football player.
And one of the reasons that I find this race
so disturbing is that Herschel Walker quite
literally cannot speak.
Herschel Walker.
Walker is incoherent.
Herschel Walker cannot explain his views on
any political issue.
Herschel Walker will not debate Raphael Warnock,
but is starting to claim that Warnock is actually
the one who won't debate him.
It is extraordinarily disturbing because you
have a man who quite literally cannot speak.
It's impossible to know what he thinks about
anything.
And he's only down like a point to the incumbent
Democratic Senator, Raphael Warnock.
Take a look at some of these new clips that
I have from Herschel Walker.
At a rally.
I guess it's called a rally, although it's
not clear whether I mean, this could be a
eulogy or a rally.
You can't tell.
It's not clear whether this is a happy event
or a sad event or what because it's not clear
what he's talking about.
Here is Herschel Walker talking about a bull
in a field with six cows.
So tell me if you can understand what he's
talking about here.
Speaker 4: This is a story not heard one time.
It's about everybody thinking something is
better somewhere else.
And I mean, I'm talking about this book that
was out in the field, and he had six cal women,
three on one to speak, and came Daddy £6.
But what he worried about, he kept his nose
up against the fence, seeing these other three
cows on the hillside.
Speaker 1: Oh, is this like a grass is greener
parable?
Speaker 4: But he looking up on a hillside
and he's of three cows, not worried about
what he don't.
Now, the grass is as tall as his knee, and
all he has to do is eat great.
But he's worried about something else.
And so one day we measure that fence up a
measure that gets up.
And he said, you know, I think I can jump
this fence.
You don't know about the cow?
No.
Not worried about what he got.
I didn't get over there.
So as he got right one afternoon, he took
off running and he dole and he made it over.
The fence is better.
Got all caught up his stuff.
He rolled up and he got up and he knew he
would have made it on on the side.
He was so excited about it.
And then he ran to the top of the hill.
When he got up there, he realized they were
bulls to him.
And the reason I tell you that I don't think
something is better somewhere.
Speaker 1: Okay.
I mean, I guess he's saying in a very strange
way, don't fall for the grass is greener on
the other side and.
Okay, fine.
Here's another story of a guy who got to the
pearly gates and it was a trick of some kind.
Speaker 4: And this is about the story of
this man who died.
And he went to heaven early.
And when he got to heaven, Saint Peter met
him at the pearly gates.
And Saint Peter said, You're here early right
now.
And your name on the roll.
But he said, I'm going to give you an opportunity
to decide where you want to go.
He said, You can go to heaven or you can go
to hell, and I'll give you a chance to decide
for yourself.
And he puts them in his elevator and he takes
him all the way down to Hale.
And the doors open up.
And as a party going on.
And a lot of his friends down there, and they're
having a good time.
And so after a couple of hours ago, Saint
Peter came to him and said, We got to leave
now.
We got to leave because we got to go.
We said, here, you got to go right now.
So he puts him in his elevator.
He takes them all the way up to heaven, and
they get to heaven and the doors open up.
And as people are floating around and clouds,
they're having a good time.
Dear God.
And a couple of hours they came to him and
said, Are you ready to make the decision?
Andy Garcia.
Well, St Pete.
I hate to tell you this, but I think I want
to go to jail.
So are you sure that he.
Speaker 1: Really has a way with words?
Speaker 4: Know is this thing like my type
of place?
So he puts them in his elevator.
They go all the way down to hell.
Nine When the doors open up.
Now it's hot.
Hot in India.
Today is hot.
Yeah.
Looking miserable.
That terrible.
That's just crying.
Speaker 1: Okay.
I'm not going to subject you to the to the
rest of it, folks.
This guy's polling 46% in Georgia I'm sorry,
45% in Georgia right now.
If you look at polling Georgia Senate Herschel
Walker versus Raphael Warnock, Walker is only
behind by on average one point.
In fact, the latest poll from Emerson has
Walker ahead by two.
Now, maybe you don't agree with everything
Raphael Warnock stands for.
Maybe you don't like all of his policy positions.
But we send 100 people to the U.S. Senate,
and some intellectual capacity and cognitive
ability should be a requirement.
And this is not about you know, I know every
time we talk about this, David, while you're
making fun of people who have mental illness,
does Walker have mental illness?
And I'm not making fun of that.
You're making fun of people who have a brain
injury.
Does Walker have a brain injury?
I'm not making fun of that.
What?
This is a position that has certain intellectual
requirements, or at least it should.
So it's an even if those things were true
about Herschel Walker, it would still not
be a reason to make him a United States senator.
Here's one bonus.
Here's Walker, I guess, outlining his educational
plan in our schools.
Have you.
Speaker 4: Seen it?
Oh, kids, I'll be happy.
Unidentified: To go to the.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Speaker 4: What about teaching them how to
write?
What?
I teach them how to read.
What about teaching them how to spell?
Yeah, but right now, we would like the people
to watch that war profit of the blacks out
of misery that give it to us.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Woke profits are the reason.
I guess school is bad at this point in time.
So I know people have been emailing me, emailing
me and saying, David, you know, I've seen
a lot of morons be elected to public office.
You know, I was around for the Bush era and
then Trump.
But there's something about if Walker wins,
that they will be completely despondent.
And I have to tell you that I get it.
I really do.